[Aplausos]
[Música]
o ya la verdad es que estoy un poco
feliz y nervioso y decepcionado también
porque yo venía con muchísimo entusiasmo
y creía que iba a ser el primer speaker
en dar su plática en crocs pero
investigue y hay una niña gringa que la
dio entre los blancos pero si les puedo
decir que merezco un gran aplauso porque
soy el primer joven mexicano en dar su
plática en crowd rojos
ahí está mi premio ahora voy
cuando yo en el avión rumbo a calcuta
india cargaba con muchísimas cosas pero
había dos cosas muy importantes primero
un corazón lleno de ganas pero sobre
todo de hambre y de sed pero no sabía de
qué iba inquieto en el avión y yo sí que
voy a hacer aquel curso no tengo idea no
lo empecé a ver la película de lion y
dije es que no sé a dónde está yendo
y otra cosa que era una fórmula que yo
creía que era muy segura y yo vivía con
ella durante toda mi vida que había
aprendido aquí en monterrey con mi
familia con mis amigos una fórmula que
me daba felicidad pero que era difícil
de cumplir
si yo recibía la aprobación de los demás
por mis trabajos por mis proyectos y me
aplaudían
pues yo empezaba a ser un poco más feliz
que es algo no tan fácil de obtener si
lo sumo a la preparación profesional a
un buen estudio a diplomados a creer
quizás trofeos medallas me da un poco
más felicidad porque me la gente empieza
a probar y la otra son los talentos los
talentos que yo tengo que me fueron
dados si los hago y lo sumo con todo
esto pues me da como resultado la
felicidad pero conforme fui caminando en
la ciudad de calcuta que es una ciudad
bella pero diferente y que les deseo la
oportunidad de que puedan ir alguna vez
ustedes caminan en la ciudad hay mucho
ruido hay mucho tráfico hay olores de
todo tipo hay gente que va al baño en
las calles es súper divertido se lo
recomiendo
hay carros hay desorden eso es todo lo
que encuentras pero muy bonito y cada
vez que me enfrentaba con las personas
que encontraba en calcuta esta formula
siga rompiendo y este camino no era
caminar a ver a donde me encontraba sino
que yo aprenda aprendan es la casa donde
las hermanas de la caridad cuidan a los
ancianos ya las personas que encuentran
en la calle los toman y los cuidan y
nuestra rutina era sencilla íbamos a la
mañana lavamos la ropa la sacábamos la
tendríamos limpiamos el lugar que está
enorme cubetazos súper pesados y pues
lamento estoy til y pues no voy a cargar
mucho y limpiar el piso después damos de
comer los acompañamos los rasurada nos
recortaron las uñas exportamos el pelo
se hacían todo tipo de actividades se
los podían ocurrir y la verdad les dio
mucha pasta a mis papás porque cuando
sean ancianos ya saben que yo los puedo
acompañar toda la guerra
y para que sean un poco de cuenta había
un viejito que no podía ver y siempre
hacía ruido como quería al baño y tú lo
tenías acompañarlo por la verdad nadie
quiera acompañar al y no al baño
entonces ya es terminando y el visito ya
te agarraba y dije pues bueno ni modo me
toca y lo llevó se lo llevó acompañó al
baño obviamente pues él trabaja todo lo
que se tiene que bajar no me lo va a
bajar aquí y se sientan o si sabían pero
en ese lugar de calcuta no siento o
india no puede generalizar no utilizan
papel de baño para limpiarse entonces
utilizan la mano izquierda para
limpiarse entonces yo llevo la cuenta de
agua el señor se sienta muy agusto
bailén feliz de la vida y yo viendo
llegó a qué increíble entonces se limpia
y ya cuando acabó todo en orden no tan
bonito
me quiere tomar de la mano yo no no no
no hermano no me agarres con esa verdad
y hablando en español ya no sabía yo
hermano para innovar pero para que se
den cuenta el tipo de trabajo que
teníamos todas las mañanas en prenda
la verdad es que cada vez que iba
haciendo esto encontraba mucha felicidad
pero seguía sintiendo mi corazón como
atrapado no sabía porque sentía como que
no era libre sería con hambre sería con
sed y no lo estaba encontrando y me
encontré con dos cosas dos cadenas muy
pesadas que me di cuenta cuando estaba
ayudando un viejito y empecé a hacerlo
con más amor y con más pasión porque
llegaron mis compañeros yo fui con un
grupo amigos que respeto y admiro con
todo el corazón y al momento de estar
con ellos pues me sentía bien de que me
vieran ediciones que diego extra es
súper cool y diego extra es súper bueno
y siempre sonríe entonces yo tenía que
cumplir esas expectativas entonces lo
estaba haciendo porque me estaban viendo
y esas fueron las dos cadenas que me
encontré una del lado izquierdo que
empezaba a hacer las cosas porque me
estaban viendo y cuántas veces no
hacemos eso no yo en lo personal me
encontraba todas las mañanas haciéndolo
nada de paz y nada de felicidad y la
segunda que yo creo que es la más pesada
y más difícil de romper
comencé a hacer las cosas
y no empecé a dejarlas de hacer porque
me estaban viendo entonces el caño mejor
estar con un viejito muy bonito y le
empezaba a cantar no yo está cantar la
canción de yo no sé mañana por eso la
fusión y yo no sé mañana y así padrísimo
no y en eso llegan mis compañeros y yo
pienso que se van a saber y ahora pensar
que yo lo estoy haciendo porque me están
viendo y eso van a pensar que soy un
falso y que lo hago para llamar la
atención todo retorcido y pensamientos
dando cuenta cómo eran cadenas que me
pesaban y que no me dejaban ser libre al
final me di cuenta mientras estaba
lavando yo solo unos platos me frente
con una oportunidad yo sentía estas
cadenas y realmente no sabía qué hacer
un día el que seguía unos de mi equipo
se enfermaron y no pudieron ir yo tuve
la oportunidad de decir que no y decir
la verdad hoy descanso es muy cansado
nos despertamos muy temprano la voy a
hacer como muchas cosas en la vida fue
obligado a tomar una decisión y después
va voy a ir solo fui con un equipo
estadounidenses que no conocía y
mientras iba trabajando cada mañana
y va experimentando como cierta libertad
y cierta alegría y cantaba con todo el
entusiasmo y sonreían y limpiaba y hacía
chistes y platicaba y no sentía ninguna
mirada porque estas personas pues no las
conocía y no las he vuelto a ver y esto
fue hace un año
y entonces mientras lavaba escondido y
yo cantaba dije es que esto es la
libertad y esto es lo que está buscando
mi corazón no si su corazón esté
buscando eso probablemente pero mi
corazón estaba buscando esa autenticidad
esa libertad de que nadie me viera hice
el clic es muy natural que estemos
buscando la aprobación de los demás el
error es que ponemos nuestro valor
intrínseco que tenemos porque existimos
en la aprobación ajena y es un factor
externo que no puedes controlar algún
día está tu amigo el otro día ya nuestro
amigo ya no te aprueba
te rompe la pierna ya no es el equipo de
fútbol ya no eres bueno y ya no eres
valioso
y me di cuenta no tiene nada de malo
pero tu valor y tu libertad y toxicidad
no puede depender de los factores
externos entonces dije es la fórmula si
yo me sé valioso me puedo dar la
oportunidad de ser más libre y como yo
me sé valioso me doy la oportunidad de
venirme en crocs y no me importa que me
juzgue
y si lo sumo
pues puedo ser más auténtico y se va
haciendo la cadena entre más valioso me
sé más libre poseer y entre más libre
pueda ser más autenticidad puedo llevar
al mundo qué es lo que tanto necesita y
que al final lleva a la felicidad qué es
lo que todos estamos buscando y la
verdad es que ser auténtico implica un
compromiso contigo mismo de seguir tu
corazón y les digo un compromiso porque
venía en el carro ahí me encanta la
música en español que sí con dos
hermanos hombres mayores a mí me juzgan
mucho por el tipo de música que
escuchaban entonces venía escuchando yo
la camioneta hard me acuerdo un grupo
son dos hermanas y qantas y muy
romántico ni me los el asunto entonces
yo venía la camioneta y mamá manejando
súper a gusto yo con la música todo y yo
me entrego a ti en este momento gozando
la
y en eso pues digo pues porque no
ventanas abajo bomba el lugar volteo el
lado izquierdo y un taxista ahoga de
risa y yo
no se crean no se crean tengo un carro y
yo creo que eso es quizá el menos hombre
iba a pensar de voy a escuchar otra
música no o sea a pesar de que este soy
yo
me pesaba los factores externos y
cuántas veces nos pasa el sueño nos
damos cuenta
y les platico que tuve una experiencia
con unos chavos de secundaria que les
estaba dando un taller y les hablaba de
la autenticidad y lo importante de saber
identificarse con lo que nos gusta y lo
que somos en realidad y es un compromiso
porque ahí les abre mi corazón a estos
chavos que están como lea y como hay que
es que me está saliendo de ellos que me
gustan las niñas y sudó y está todo
incómodos bueno eso me pasó a mí y no sé
a ustedes no ven como y les abrí mi
corazón y les di la oportunidad de
hacerlo y les dije me gusta esto veo
vídeos de quinceañeras en las noches
bailando en un tiro que sale así y
lograron se cambió el vestido y salen
los congresistas súper loco así lo hago
y pues no lo hago en público verdad pero
así soy
y un niño o una niña dice no es que yo
quiero compartir algo me gusta la música
en francés y yo a bruto y todos
aplaudimos oye pues no es raro y luego
otro niño dice es que colecciono las
piedras y todos aplaudimos dijimos ahí
pues no le hace daño a nadie y luego
otro niño así enfrente en la primera
fila como como tú vas de cuenta más
gordito y de esos niños que ya no tienen
a mano estar bonita yo estoy útil y él
está gordito de esos niños que les
llevan un buen lonche no sé a qué de qué
doble esta noche sí y sudando el hombre
literal y levanta la mano y si yo quiero
compartir algo me encanta ver
telenovelas todos ahogados de risa a un
niño de 13 años compartiendo eso todos
se lo quieran acabar todos comiendo lo
acabamos las niñas hasta caso de
realizar no hacer que con él y le dije
esto es ser hombre esto es ser auténtico
comprometerte hacer tú en no tener ese
miedo de estarlo compartiendo a los
demás
es que les quiero confesar que amo con
locura a high school musical
me encanta o sea yo me sé todo el paso
por toda la canción y me costaba por el
hecho que tenía dos hermanas mayores y
personas de hombres escuchar rock and
roll soul entonces me veía buscando y
silicio o sea ni saco isi disi prodi si
puedo hacer qué significa ser hombre y
ser súper cool
y es un ejercicio tonto
pero también
me puedo tomar la libertad de aquí
hacerlo
y así como les confieso que me gusta
high school musical no hay mañana que no
dude de mí no hay mañana que no me
compare
desde hace tiempo ya hace rato hace
mucho le compartí la abrí mi corazón a
una persona que era como un papá para mí
no era mi papá y me lastimó y me desecho
como una hoja sin querer tal vez no no
estoy de xian malito a tono muchas veces
lastimamos y no nos damos cuenta y me
desecho y me lastimó y me ha costado
tanto y me ha hecho dudar tanto de mi
valor todos los días
dudo es que no sé valioso es que no lo
hago bien es que no soy suficiente
nunca le da un beso a nadie
las interesadas al final
y la verdad este es el momento para
ustedes de si alguien quiere externar
algo y vivir esa libertad que yo probé y
que estoy tratando de ejercer y
autenticidad es un momento de decirle al
mundo lo que sienten o lo que son
un aplauso
[Música]
y qué es lo que pasa todo el mundo nos
dice es que ese auténtico i be yourself
y eres tú y tú lo puesto y brillas y
eres súper especial pero como dice la
frase antes de ser auténtico pero nada
me dice quién soy
ahí está la pregunta que hay que
responder y yo está buscando pues la
verdad que significa ser auténtico cómo
puedo ser yo auténtico
y la verdad construyendo una definición
me di cuenta que eso significa ser
auténtico identificarte con lo bueno que
hay dentro de ti
ver videos de la rosa de guadalupe no sé
pero un talento me gusta estudiar
soy introvertido soy super extrovertido
me encanta platicar
soy bueno en los deportes soy bueno en
la oratoria soy bueno en x y z eso eres
realmente y eso hay que ejercer y eso
hay que practicar pero también es
importante no irnos con cualquier cosa
que sienta nuestro corazón porque
también tenemos ciertas cosas por
nuestra historia ciertas heridas que
tenemos a cosas malas entonces no me
vais a decir es que yo entonces soy un
drogo porque pues yo me drogo y eso soy
pues no eres eso estás luchando con eso
pero eso no te hace tu valor intrínseco
y la verdad yo no quiero que después de
aquí me llamara que alguien hoy digo es
que te estoy marcando es el penal porque
osea yo amo robar y yo amo drogarme lo
tenía que hacer pero tú me dijiste que
fuera auténtico ahí está la línea
el ser auténtico no daña a nadie ni a tu
familia ni a ti mismo sino hace puro
bien y que les doy para que vivan esta
autenticidad una fórmula que yo practico
la primera es saber quién eres y
ejercerlo porque una cosa es haber abuso
y diego estrada social y dador de vidas
me gusta esto esto no me gusta estos son
mis amigos estos no son mis amigos pero
otra cosa es ya lo sé pero no lo hago
hay que ejercerlo y es un ejercicio y un
compromiso yo tuve que ir a terapia un
año y medio porque me sentía incómodo y
no sabía que estaba sintiendo a pesar de
tener todo bajo control porque pues toda
la sociedad dice ten todo bajo control
porque si no estás súper mal entonces
dije sabes que no puedo fui en mi auto
conocí dije este soy sé lo que me gusta
y sé lo que no me gusta si lo sumo a no
compararte y es mi lucha de todos los
días y cuando lo siento realmente me
encuentro para en la calle corriendo
gritando escuchando en mi canción y
gritando me eres valioso eres valioso
eres valioso es valioso hasta que me
entra en el corazón porque lo hace aquí
el problema es que caiga aquí
y no es fácil pero es una grosería
compararte porque cada uno de nosotros
somos un misterio somos algo especial me
choca la gente que es que nadie se
especial porque si todos somos
especiales entonces todos somos iguales
callate si eres así realmente todos
somos únicos y tenemos un proyecto de
vida hay una vocación específica que si
yo lo dejo hacer nadie más lo va a ser
eso me lo dijo mi amiga hace un aplauso
para hacer muy buenas
y también amigos de verdad y los amigos
de verdad te hacen llorar te hacen
llorar porque te comparten disney es el
amor de mi vida no sé quién es o no pero
si te dicen oye
qué buena amistad y aprovecha si vives
experiencias increíbles pero también te
corrigen y te dicen ese no eres tú y si
yo llego con mi amigo y es que amo robar
no entiendes como me encanta agarrar las
galletas maría y terminas a la bolsa
irme me decir hermano por ahí no va eso
no significa ser auténtico con eso no te
puedes identificar y no puedes ir por la
vida no y esto nos da la verdadera
autenticidad que la verdadera
autenticidad es esa libertad que tanto
deseas por eso el título de plática la
verdadera libertad pues es la
autenticidad la de atreverme a ser yo ya
reconocer que ese misterio que ni tú
entiendes ese misterio que repente
sientes bien te enojas te gusta algo no
te gusta
pues es un misterio que hay que
descubrir y que el mundo necesita y que
por las cosas buenas y las cosas malas
que haces
no significa que sea como todo lo que
haya 0 es que si soy un ladrón soy
horrible lo que sea
lo importante es reconocer que es un
misterio por descubrir
que realmente la verdadera libertad es
de atreverte a ser auténtico a confesar
a comprometerte a ser tú porque el mundo
necesita eso y este mundo necesita
personas auténticas que se atrevan a
salir y no va a aprender a emprender a
emprender como el rayo emprendedor que
nos ataca y si que perdón por depender
hay que seguir este camino autenticidad
y hacer lo que nos gusta y lo que
deseamos y darnos cuenta que esta vida
sólo hay una que tenemos tantas
oportunidades y si algo quiero que se
acuerden es que nunca pero nunca te
olvides
que tu vida es increíble gracias
[Música]